hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my newsletter readers gary
who wrote insane I hope you're doing
well so an article on my friend's
Facebook page glad I checked it out that
was able to gain some insight I'm glad I
could help there Gary my biggest
challenge right now I several my newest
venture is a two sided marketing company
one is contract with commercial property
owners to build an attractive portfolio
to shop to advertisers to is a sell
product to advertisers I've learned that
property is necessary to sell product
this said I have no experience in
commercial property and the REITs we're
targeting are typically a tough nut to
crack I feel I need someone with skill
set expertise but can't afford to hire
anyone until getting into revenue
everyone that works with me to date is
doing so on a profiteering basis but I
haven't been able to get the experience
commercial real estate person to buy
into this methodology I appreciate any
feedback learn more birthing and website
so let's go check out Gary's website oh
this is a cool idea so what I love about
this site is you can immediately
understand what he does so he takes
these polls and turns them into the odds
and from the email I was having a hard
time understanding it but this picture
is awesome and this is this is a good
lesson for a lot of entrepreneurs you
want people to really understand right
away what you do when they come and land
on your homepage so this is a great
picture and you maybe should have
included that in your email Gary because
now I really understand what it is that
you do looking around some more this is
interesting here so send an email for
free mock up this this kind of gets lost
and this could be really powerful for
you if people could send you their polls
and you could send back an example what
it would look like with their logos a
big problem when you put when you have
such a visible picture people tend to
their eyes will go here read this and
it'll go down and they'll miss what's up
here so you might want to put something
you know
this and put it below and also include a
graphic with it to encourage people to
send that email in because if I think
it's a great idea if they can see it
with their logo on it they're more
likely to want to take that next step
and work with you so awesome idea just
make that more visible this slogan is
not something I understand so I guess
it's Linna people would I guess that's
point-of-purchase I don't know the OO H
stands for but I guess it's something
that your clients but understand so it's
fine as long as I guess they do
understand what that means then then
it's an okay slogan the next thing I
would think of is how much is this cost
so that is a cool idea a great way to
promote my business if I'm a retailer
especially but how much is this cost I'm
what is the return on investment so you
know if I have an opportunity to buy
this versus putting up a new traditional
sign what's the return on this versus
something else I don't know if you have
any data on that I see mobile marketing
here so I guess you could have you know
text a certain number to another number
and you can kind of track how many
people are actually using that if you
have any kind of case studies that would
be great to see right here it may be new
and you don't have clients yet or
they're small clients without data but
something right away here to show that
people are benefiting from your service
I would put even it was just a
testimonial from somebody who's was
using it that would be great to see
that's that's the biggest thing now is
okay it looks cool but how much is the
cost and am I gonna get a return on it
in terms of the target customer I think
I would go after the the retail clients
first instead of the property owners I'm
not sure how much interest the property
owners would have in this but if you
could go to them and show them that the
retail tenants are interested right so
this Randi's burger joint if you went to
them and said hey we want to turn you
know all the poles in the parking lot
into Randy's burger joint odds
would you be interested in here's a
rough cost then you could take that to
the property owners and say hey we have
this new potential revenue opportunity
for you
and then you're you know making it
easier for them to say yes instead of
bringing them an opportunity when now
they're faced with tons of decisions
every day and as you said are hard not
to crack so I try to make an arrangement
with the retail clients first and then
bring that to the property owner and
you're bringing them free revenue if you
do some kind of split I don't know you
know how much you need to make your
margins work but that could be
interesting opportunity and a lot of
these guys that the malls and the strip
malls have multiple locations so if it
works in one place and they're seeing a
return and they're able to generate new
revenue from it then they could
potentially do it you know across the
state across the country across North
America
I guess depends on how big the chain is
that you're dealing with but they could
take you into other opportunities if you
make it work once the next thing I would
think about is how hard is this to
replicate so you know great randy says
yes and you take it to the the property
owner and they say you know great let's
let's do something we're almost a great
idea but there's a they're gonna think
of cutting you out of the equation right
you may think this is just a simple you
know printed a simple aluminum column
when you you print something on the
outside what can't we use our
traditional suppliers for this it says
you are patent-pending
here so that's interesting and good
especially if you're looking for any
kind of investment but this to me
doesn't look that hard to duplicate and
I don't mean to to insult what you've
created here I think is that an
interesting idea but it's going to be
something that whoever your clients are
they'll think to themselves that it's
not that complicated to duplicate as
well so you definitely want to show I
have a good reason for why they should
use you and pay a premium over using of
their traditional sign guys who might
look at this and say oh yeah we could do
that too so
given the option they'd rather work with
you know existing suppliers so they have
relationship with that might already be
leveraging some efficiencies and
quantity of scale than to work with a
new supplier who might be charging them
more so I definitely want to have a good
answer for that as to why they should
use you and not just go with somebody
else and then in terms of your question
of hiring people that's always tough it
is hard to bring guys on for a
commission only model I don't know how
much you're giving away is Commission
you definitely wanna make sure there's
enough margin to motivate so it depends
on how much you actually gonna be making
from this but you know the more you can
give away and afford to give away the
the better people you're gonna attract
right if it's not an interesting
opportunity it's gonna be harder to get
somebody on board you might look at some
kind of partnership arrangement but
again you have to find the right person
getting the business partner is like
getting married it's a long-term
commitment and you don't want to jump
into bed with the wrong person there's a
lot of stories about partnerships that
people had with their companies
I honestly think your best bet is to
start doing this yourself and and prove
to yourself that that this can work and
get some you know feedback and some
momentum going by talking to some of
these retail clients and seeing if they
would pay for this and if they would
then you can go to the property owners
and they might even introduce you to the
property owners and you know you have
something you can expand on if all the
retail guys you go talk to I'll tell you
hey you know what this this isn't
something we would look at and you're
getting some pretty good feedbacks in
the market and then might give you some
other ideas on what you could do to make
it more effective but I think honestly
your best bet is going to be you going
out talking with these retailers and
pitching them the idea and seeing if
there's something that they would
whittle Contour not a very interesting
business again I love how easy it is to
understand what you do and I love this
thing here I definitely try to put that
lower and bigger so it stands out so
people can submit their
pictures and she's and they could see
what it would look like I think that's a
really powerful tool that you offer so
congrats on on setting that part up I
hope that helped Gary for those of you
watching if you enjoyed please give it a
thumbs up these videos are free and I
love doing them to help you guys out so
whenever you give a thumbs up it helps
make my day a little bit and if you have
a comment about this product or this
website or you want me to check out
something on your website feel free to
leave the message in the comments below
and we'll see you on the next episode
you